[Music]
[Applause]
hi and welcome to episode number 115 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mach mantle and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick Melanie how
are you doing today great how are you
doing I'm doing great you're here in the
studio with me so I'm super happy I'm
still in the studio never left no after
this I will actually be heading out to
New York to go to fat star but but
that's for us to discuss later at the
end of the podcast yeah but today we
have a really interesting interview with
two people dumb Elliott and Stewart
Bryson dumb works for Google Play and
they are basically a client that uses
Google cloud platform to look at
analytics across Google Play and Stuart
Bryson is one of the people who helped
build it so we'll have a fun chat with
them but as always we always talk about
our cool things a week and we end with a
question of the week and this week's
question is if you want to be able to
unit test your integrations with
kubernetes with client go
how can you mock what happens inside the
cluster in your unit tests mocking is
always a challenge we'll get back to
that one so cool things of the week I'm
gonna start this week and mention how
Amy Andrew who's one of our developer
advocates who we had on the podcast
couple weeks back talking about Auto ml
she's put together a blog post that's
talking about easy distributed training
with tensorflow using the TF estimator
train and evaluate on cloud ml engine
this is something that allows it to more
easily train and transfer models whether
you're running it locally or distributed
in the cloud she gives a nice overview
how to do that especially specifically
using cloud ml engine but this is
something that you can use with
different infrastructures like cloud
engine container engine Google App
Engine so she gives a nice insight
around what to think about and how to
approach this and how do you use train
and evaluate and we will definitely link
that in the show notes as we always do
this I will go next
one lovely contribution from community
member on medium CI CD with less fluff
and more awesome written by I'm gonna go
with Rick Naruto I'm gonna guess that's
right he's writing about basically by
combining several different things cloud
builder an open source product called
keel pub/sub helm github and kubernetes
putting that all together into a
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipeline so that basically
they can write code turn it into a
container put that container into a
registry and then deploy that container
up into kubernetes as well it's actually
quite a thorough article that has lots
of code in it so if you're looking to
build a continuous delivery pipeline and
maybe you're interested in any of those
products you might want to take a look
yes definitely and last thing that's
cool thing of the week is that we
basically have generally availability on
the Google compute engine machine types
with 96b CPUs that have up to six
hundred twenty four gigabytes of memory
so basically you can now and take
advantage of performance improvements
and increased core count provided by the
new Intel Xeon scalable processors the
skylight nice yeah and that works both
across custom machine types as well as
predefined machine types as well so more
cores more small course better all right
well mark I think it's time to go talk
with our guests for this week's podcast
let's go do that then today I am excited
and pleased to have two people here
joining us today doma
elliot who is the global developer
marketing communications person for
Google Play as well as Stuart Bryson who
is the owner and co-founder of red pill
analytics they're here today to talk
just about how they've used GCP with
Google Play marketing how are you both
doing today Tom how are you doing yeah
very good things thanks for having me
I'm over in cold London excellent Stuart
how are you doing today I'm doing
fantastic it's a little cold in Atlanta
but probably not London cold so I'm
happy oh oh I didn't really you're in my
old home hometown I lived in Atlanta for
a number years excellent excellent
well before we get stuck into talking
about Google Play marketing and what you
did with Google cloud why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourselves and
what you do dump do you want to go first
sure
so I'm on the Google Play team my goal
is to help Android app and game
developers be successful on Google Play
and the way I do that is to lead the
columns we do out to developers so we
tell them about our new product launches
on Android and Google Play help them
understand our features produce case
studies and then use various marketing
channels to reach them like our website
developers 200 calm and we use YouTube
vlogs medium social channels a lot of
email marketing we speak at events all
those kind of things awesome
Stewart your Anika sure yeah the owner
and co-founder of red pill analytics
we're a company that's about 4 years old
ploy around 30 people in the US and
Brazil and one individual in the UK we
focus on analytics that's our sort of
bread and butter the beginning of our
company we were firmly an on-prem
analytics software company and about two
years ago we we made the transition to
trying to go after the public cloud and
really helping all sized organizations
really move their either new
implementations or their existing
analytics workloads into the public
cloud great well so you both have been
working together on this project can you
tell us a little bit about the project
yeah sure I'll start as I mentioned we
use a lot of different channels to
communicate with developers and we have
a really large engaged developer
community who develop for Android it's
the world's most popular operating
system and we try and we want to make
sure that we're measuring sort of the
health of the ecosystem and checking
that we're reaching the right developers
and that they're engaged with our
channels and content to make sure that
we can understand how they engage with
our content and our channels and so in
the past we've done this in a fairly
manual way every marketing channel we
use like our website or YouTube or our
social media accounts they all have
their own products that you can log into
to start to pull data to see how many
people you're reaching what they think
of your content and where people are
engaged and that kind of thing and it
would be super manual you know we do
every month
whenever we need to pull a report you've
got to go into a dozen places pull all
this data try and present it nicely in
Google slides and then share it around
internally it's just a big waste of time
if you're doing that you're not putting
your effort into actually creating
content and engaging with partners and
helping people so we thought that there
was a better way which is when we
started looking into what Google
Analytics specifically deadest you you
could do and how that could work with
Google cloud platform to actually pull
all that data in one place how did you
end up connecting up with Stewart on the
project sister it was actually a
recommendation of a colleague of mine we
wanted someone with some expertise on
these various products take a studio and
cloud platform and I think it was a
daisy a colleague who mentioned rep Hill
analytics so we got in touch we're so
glad they did we approached this very
much you know even though it was Google
and Google's a big big company obviously
but Dom's team is just a group of
marketers right so marketing
communications so we approach this very
much as we would you know any marketing
company really although they are Google
and most of the avenues and digital
channels that we were interested in or
Google platforms their public Google
platforms so this implementation will be
applicable for for really any
organization we knew that also that
because Don's team really didn't have
access to engineering resources we
wanted to make this really easy we
wanted it to be something that they
could support once we left which was
very very important to us and so the
Google cloud platform is perfect so we
focused on serverless technologies as
much as possible we focused on things
that would just scale and continue
running once we left and the platform
really provided a lot of technologies we
could use really pretty easily so I just
saw this 100% clear as well even though
you're both basically working for Google
Play you're basically like an external
company using gzp there's really no
difference here you're not getting any
particularly special treatment as far as
I can tell no yeah exactly from a
marketing perspective we we're pulling
all this data from essentially public
api's via Google Analytics YouTube
analytics and so on and then even some
other non
platforms like Twitter and LinkedIn yeah
it's very much an API driven approach we
did utilize bigquery data transfer
service which is also available to
anyone to pull some things straight from
from Google platforms but in general the
main approach was to go after API is all
of these social media and digital
channels have api's data readily
available we just needed to consume it
and ingest it in a straightforward way
get it into bigquery eventually and and
then just let the power of data studio
really give DOM and his team a single
point of access for all this data so
that they can see which channels are
performing which channels are reaping
the most benefits from their outreach
and is there a reason why you chose to
go with GCP versus using internal tools
I know I'm not really sure what
intention for the suite years most of
our internal tools are kind of we
measure very closely usage of our
products and things like that so I work
on a product called Google Play console
which is how others publish their apps
and kind of manage their app business on
Google Play so we look very closely at
usage and engagement of that and see
which features are working and so on but
there wasn't an obvious internal tool to
pull together the various sort of
marketing channels that we're talking
about like web and video and email and
things like that so I'm sure some clever
Google engineer could have built
something from scratch but it totally it
just it just seemed rias for us to use
this what was publicly available cool so
I want to take a step back because we've
mentioned sort of the end product in
passing and we're not a visual medium
unfortunately so people can't see it but
um can you kind of explain the end
result like what do you see here what is
data studio give you like what is the
actual product that you have finally
built at the very end then maybe we can
move backwards from there sure I would
sort of describe it as a you know if you
were kind of traditional it's like a
living a living version of a
presentation and each slide is
essentially a report on a different
marketing channel that we use and it's
really visual it's in data studio it's
got grass and stats and each graph has
sort of trends versus previous months
we've sort of sliced data based on
different things like country or
engagement by differ
sort of dimensions depending on what the
data is we have about 11 11 different
pages in this report one for each of our
main marketing channels going from web
to email to ads to video to like blog
posts and then social and then events as
well and as part of it used to help
decide where to spend more efforts
towards different marketing channels
like what are some of the decisions that
you like to make off of this at a high
level it helps us understand the health
of each channel are these channels
growing are there particular countries
which are very engaged or not very
engaged where we should dial up or dial
down our efforts for specific channels
we can see if you know for the app data
we pull them from firebase for example
when we release an update is that
resulting in a sudden increase or a
sudden drop in engagement
we can see those kind of things and then
it helps us a lot with the various
pieces of content we put out on channels
as well it helps us with like
optimization and planning going forward
cool another use of the report is
internal reporting essentially so we can
tell various stakeholders and all the
other teams the product team business
development team are various VPS when
they just want to dive in and just get a
snapshot of what's going on see how
engaged the developer community is in
various places they can do that really
easy now
when those kind of fire drills came in
in the past you know we would all have
to like run along and pull all that data
on the fly but now we just have it all
in one place
lovely so Stuart I'm gonna come to you
now we're at the GCPD podcast you
mentioned previously that this was a lot
of serverless stuff sort of unmanaged as
much as possible what what products did
you actually use to build this whole
data pipeline yeah we went through
several iterations and when the total
project linked was about three months we
took a look at really the landscape of
all the products we could use we
initially considered data flow but
really for these you know for instance
Twitter has a streaming API and
JavaScript really fit the bill well so
at the very sort of heart of this is app
engine app engine is the the application
is pulling all the different social
media api's so app engine grabs that
stuff and initially our first iteration
was just app engine to bigquery some
great node packages for writing
directly to bigquery from JavaScript and
that was sort of the initial iteration
but then we started to rethink it as we
added additional social media channels
so we went after Twitter and then
LinkedIn and then we we looked at medium
so as we architected this in a very
iterative way we started introducing
some other aspects so pub/sub became
valuable for us because initially were
streaming data we're using the streaming
API to pull data from Twitter but that
doesn't give us likes and retweets the
streaming API doesn't give that and
that's really what what Dom's team was
was super interested in so we had to use
the batch API against Twitter to pull
all those retweets and likes and pub/sub
subscriptions made it very easy for us
to manage going at the data from sort of
multiple avenues and then again we
started to sort of as we ingested more
and more social media sources we
introduced cloud functions and cloud
functions allowed us to to be a little
bit more event-driven and how these
different sort of social media messages
are processed so the final architecture
was really app engine pulling data from
all of these different places
ingesting into pub/sub and then having
cloud functions react to that ingestion
and part of it was just using the
natural language API that Google has
available so we were also tracking
sentiment analysis which wasn't really
an initially one of the requirements but
it was so easy to do that we that we
started doing it and I think Don and his
team have really gotten good value out
of that aspect not just seeing how many
retweets or likes but also sort of
measuring the sentiment of those
different social media messages so
that's great that you're using cinnamon
what are some of the ways that you're
applying it in terms of utilizing it for
decisions that you're making or how are
you looking at sentiment on Twitter and
LinkedIn in particular we're seeing like
how sentiments tracking over time we're
sort of looking out for any dips or any
particular increases and seeing what are
the popular posts around that time and
because of the data we're showing we can
then go and see which handles are
getting a lot of engagement around those
tweets and then may
we can if it's something a little bit
negative we can see if we can help we
can point people to our support
resources or to our operations team if
there's something we can help with if
there's something we should escalate on
Google Play or if it's positive you know
maybe we can retweet it or look at what
the developer audience is sort of
enjoying and engaging with nice and then
Stewart there's a really great overview
in terms of the type of products that
you guys are using what were some of the
challenges you were up against when you
were building this out
well time was one of the things so we
had to build this in a reasonably quick
amount of time
three-month project for this many data
sources was I won't say daunting but it
an on-prem implementation would have
taken much much longer I think the idea
that we were just able to there's no
provisioning just just get up and get
going was an important part I think also
you know in a project like this we often
focus a lot on the data movement and how
the data is ingested and ultimately
finds its it's Homan in bigquery but
sometimes Dom had some very specific
visualization requirements he knew what
he wanted it to look like he knew how
you know he wanted to be able to present
this to to management and to the rest of
his team
so really data studio shines in that way
I mean it's it's based on on Google
Drive so it's so we could make changes
to data studio reports and dashboards as
almost watching and he could even dip
his hand in there a bit and say no I'm
thinking more like this and we could see
those changes at the same time so it's
really unusual for an analytics tool to
have that kind of interactive
capabilities and I think just the sort
of the iterative process of trying out
some visualizations seeing if it sticks
seeing if it's what Dom has in mind for
trying to report on this stuff was
really valuable so I think sort of from
a high level perspective it's just the
challenge of trying to get this many
data sources visualized in exactly the
way we wanted it was the really the
biggest challenge and I can't imagine
there is no you know analog equivalent
to trying to do that without you know
cloud architecture Stewart I got an
interesting question for you so you
mentioned a little while ago that you're
using both App Engine and cloud
functions I know
something we've talked about in the past
is like where to apply what type of sort
of compute resource to what sort of
workload yeah I'm curious to know how
you made the decision about what things
we're going to end up on App Engine and
what things would end up on cloud
functions and why so initially
everything was in App Engine so that was
just the easiest way to do it we were
pulling and in the App Engine code we
were pulling and writing to bigquery it
was as we started ingesting multiple
data sources that we realized we needed
to respond to this and more of an
event-driven manner for instance the the
Twitter example the streaming API versus
the batch API it would be difficult to
write that sort of 2-headed process in
App Engine so one of the easiest
decisions was to you know start
ingesting that stuff in the pub/sub so
that you know you could have one cloud
function that's responding to the you
know the events as they're going into
pub/sub but then App Engine was able to
continue to do the streaming side of it
so it was the sort of the approach to
trying to both pull from a from a
streaming API and also periodically
process the using the batch API some of
those same data sets we had to sort of
work through what we thought was the
life of a tweet there's a lot of
thoughts on that but I think we decided
on seven days right Dom so for seven
days we would continually look at you
know a tweet came through the streaming
API and you know it became very easy
with a cloud function to respond to
those streaming tweets and periodically
go query the batch API to find out if
there's been any retweets likes etc do
you have a rough date for how much data
you were processing like per day per
minute per hour it's really not a lot
when you look at it I mean it's we've
got some targeted hashtags targeted
handles for all these different social
media avenues and it's the other reason
why we sort of shied away from data flow
I mean data flows you know could process
huge amounts of data at scale but it
would have required us to to dip into
Java Python so the fact that App Engine
and cloud functions gave us the ability
to do a lot of this in JavaScript and
that's the best language to be working
with some of these social media api's
the question I wanted to ask is that
since clearly you've been using GCP
products you know is this common that
you see these types of combinations like
what are some things that you typically
see or the type of products that you
need to put together for your clients
yeah really when you start looking at is
the data sitting behind a REST API so in
the past when you especially with all
prim software it's everything's so
relational in nature right your source
systems are relational based your target
data warehouses or relational based I
think when you look at where it is GCP
really shine for Aleks workloads and
obviously can handle all of those use
cases as well but it's the API driven
approach that that analytics is really
moving to today and that is that data is
coming from a lot of places it's not a
single source system that that has all
all of your information as more and more
companies in our size and even companies
the size of Google a lot of their data
is sitting in a lot of disparate places
and the fact that we can write these
event-driven workflows that can go grab
this data from behind a REST API process
it in a meaningful way and also the the
iterative approach for which we were
able to you know take social media
sources architect them from from start
to finish land them and bigquery and
start building reports in just a few
days so the value that it really brings
and you know I think Don could speak to
this as well the value that it really
brings us is how quickly we were able to
hit the ground running how quickly we
were able to you know prototype a
particular digital channel develop a -
border and a report in data studio get
feedback loop back around and start that
iterative process again
and we were constantly in flow with
building and delivering additional
datasets and just the interactive and
collaborative approach the data studio
takes is really unlike any other
visualization tool that that we've
worked with the ability to be able to
just everyone collaborate on a data
studio report in the same way you would
with a
with Google Docs or Google sheets it was
really valuable from that whole
analytics process of trying to get
exactly the right visualization that
dom's team was looking for and that took
several iterations to get it just right
and we were able to do that really
easily in data studio Tom how was the
experience for you this being developed
as you being that the end user I agree
with hickory of most of what I said it
was it was great actually
I was constantly surprised at what was
possible already it was really very
helpful doing everything iteratively
because you know I had sort of rough
ideas at the very beginning but I didn't
really know what was possible in these
products and so you know how to sit down
with Stuart and Phil and we'd sort of
talked through various ideas and they
would let me know what's possible and
then they could go away and just put
something together straight away
I'm really quickly something scrappy and
we'd have a look at that and then we
could keep iterating so works really
well and then yeah as Joe mentioned
those studio has you know the front and
UI is like using Google Docs or
something so I could jump in and toggle
you know test out little changing little
things myself without actually going
into the code and dobo I'm also sort of
wondering now that you have this tool
sort of what's been the most interesting
or surprising metrics that you've been
able to pull out of it that you wouldn't
necessarily been able to do before I
think I mean a lot of this data is the
data is like buried in different places
well we didn't have the sentiment data
tool so that is really interesting some
of the things I like the most sort of
diving into different countries and just
seeing like the engagement that we get
in different countries Android is
exploding in the moment in like we call
them kind of next billion users markets
or growing markets like India and
Vietnam and Indonesia and I'm able to
see in this dashboard as well like going
through the various channels we have
like huge engagement in those regions we
can see specific countries we're really
really engaged on our channel and
consuming all this content and that's
been really great so we can then see
okay they're reading all this you know
this country say Vietnam is really
really engaged in reading a lot of
content in English and so we can do a
better job there and we can go and
localize the content because the
developer audience is there and
more content in Vietnamese for them so
those kind of those kind of loops have
been really satisfying well I know we're
getting close to time but I wanted to
ask you in both of you if what are some
key lessons learned takeaways that you
haven't already talked about that you'd
recommend to people who are considering
this type of project or something along
these lines I think be iterative you
know I've mentioned that before but but
jump in I mean one of the best things
about the Google cloud platform is that
you can you know get started on day one
for instance data studio has direct
connectors to a lot of these sources and
although we knew that we wanted to land
the data in bigquery for for posterity
sake we were able to prototype
immediately with the built-in connectors
to things like YouTube and Google
Analytics and start that whole process
of trying to figure out you know exactly
how dominus team wanted to see that data
so while you know we had one member of
the team with direct connectors from
data studio working with Tom's team
really on day one prototyping some of
the the ways that he was thinking about
visualizing this data we had other
members of the team working on capturing
that data using things like app engine
riding that dated a big query figuring
out how we wanted to store it in
bigquery and starts it was a complete
iterative process so once the data you
know took us a little time to get the
data transfer service running once that
data was landing in bigquery we slowly
refactored the data studio reports and
dashboards to go after the bigquery data
and some instances we continued to
report against the the native connectors
so we have dashboards that blend content
from the native connectors with the data
from bigquery and that sort of you know
flexibility was really eye-opening I
think in a lot of analytics projects you
spend so much time trying to land and
ingest the data and get the data just
right and then the analytics starts and
quite often that piece is kind of
brushed over because you're running out
of time your and maybe you don't get
exactly what the end user is looking for
from a visualization perspective we were
able to start the the
process immediately using the native
connectors and then just slowly refactor
over time so I think if I were to take
one major lesson from building analytics
especially a greenfield implementation
in Google cloud platform
it's just be a iterative
roll-up-your-sleeves get started and
also don't be afraid to write a little
code so you know with API is it's gonna
be difficult to find just the right
tooling to go after something that's API
driven so you've got to you know not be
afraid to use tools like cloud functions
use a tool like App Engine and pub/sub
to build you know the right event-driven
architecture cool that you done in
general I was just pleasantly surprised
it was possible I think the kind of
small amount of work upfront is really
is really worth it to like save time in
the in the long run and you can then
these reports are really flexible and
help you save time and do your job
better and on data studio in particular
I love a bunch of their visualizations
we're using now which we just weren't
using before I mean we weren't using
bubble charts at all before and now
they're one of my favorite
visualizations and we've got heat maps
and Geographic maps and just a bunch
more interesting kind of insightful
visualizations that we can start to draw
interesting conclusions from awesome
it's expanding your knowledge on the
system yeah exactly let me just jump in
there and say how easy it is to change
visualizations into and to test
particular visualizations geographies
particularly easy in data flow it just
knows when you're dealing with
geographic data the way it handles
time-based prompts for you to be able to
choose a particular time frame for
whether you want quarterly monthly
trending etc it just sort of gets all
that so the built in sort of
functionality for constants like
geography and times it's really pleasing
if you look at on-prem versions of this
kind of software that's it's not near
that easy so data studio really really
shines and in handling those sorts
types fantastic well we've definitely
run out of time but such a such a
pleasure talking to both of you Stuart
thank you for spending the time with us
today to talk about what you've been
doing over at Google Play with all your
data and data studio thanks for having
us yes thank you yeah thanks very much
for having me thanks so much to dum and
Stuart to have a chat with us about
Google platform and how it was actually
used internally inside Google not just
external customers who use it we do have
plenty of internal customers as well so
it was a really interesting conversation
yeah I agree it's nice to hear about how
the cloud platform is being used to
solve problems that we know others will
be experiencing whether they're internal
or external so questions the week if you
want to be able to unit test your
integrations with kubernetes with client
go
how can you mock what happens inside the
cluster in your unit tests mark yeah so
this is something I do a lot with
because I'm at Graham with kubernetes a
lot probably if you're familiar at all
with kubernetes you know you may be
familiar with cube CTL you're probably
familiar that from coops ETL behind that
is a crew net deus api client go is the
go client that you can use for basically
talking to kubernetes so if you want to
programmatically create pods or
deployments or pretty much anything
inside kubernetes you can do that
through client code what I don't know if
is is much known by people is there's a
whole fake section to it that enables
you to basically mock out how things
work so you create a client set with
client go and then when you want to use
it in testing you can create this fake
client set and what you can do then is
add these things called reactors to it
and I'll put links in the show notes
reactors are lovely in that you can
basically control what happens when
things happen for the client set so you
might be like lists pods and you'll add
a list pod reactor and then you'll be
like these are the pods that will be
shown now and it'll work just like it
would do as if it was connected to a
real cluster but you just have full
control over and you can basically tell
it to do whatever it is you need to do
inside your unit tests it's a really
nice testing it's hard enough so when
you have something I can help with that
that's yeah
I'll put links to the documentation the
share notes I'll also link to some demo
code I have in one of my github
repositories so you can see it in action
as well great mark and going anywhere
special in the next say moments there's
always game developer conference here at
Google the stuff I can talk about is
that we have a developer day across
Google we will have people from Google
cloud platform are people from day dream
people from
talking about that on the first day of
GU Game Developers Conference but we'll
also have talks at the booth on the show
floor as well as meet the expert
sessions and like all sorts of good
stuff that's great and I think you're
you're you're away right now I believe I
I will be away shortly and I will be
going to fat star in New York because I
was talking about earlier in the
beginning of this podcast and then I'll
come back we'll get back in the studio
together to talk about more things all
the things all the things awesome all
right well Melanie thank you so much for
joining me yet another week on the
podcast
Thank You Marc and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]